my first play school i think it was or
junior school i obviously upset one of
the girls there one of the other kids
and her mum asked my the teachers if i
could
be removed because i was upset in her
child my face didn't like it i was
scaring her
[Music]
i was born into a traveller family
my mom was a irish traveler
and i didn't know my dad my mum was
white and so was her husband
so when i came out black it kind of put
her in a difficult situation
my mum thought that i we would be
ostracized if i'd stayed in the
child of a community and the story i was
told was that
they saw someone saw my mum put me in
the in a fire
and a stranger we don't know who saved
me
in my file it just says that my mum
put me in a caravan fire and tried to
kill me
to be honest with you i didn't know too
much about what happened to my mum after
the fire
um i don't think that was proof
like physical proof i think
yeah that was a lot you know there was
no nothing they could properly pin on
any one
person so i don't think
i don't know what happened to her after
the file
was it hard growing up knowing that the
woman who gave birth to you
tried to kill you of course
it was horrible to think that you know
your mum
wants to kill you it's gonna be one of
the worst things to think but
i'm very very lucky and very grateful
and i think i always felt that i always
felt that
grateful attitude because looking back
on my mum
and what i came from and thinking you
know
what she did i thought god you know what
kind of life must she have had
to do something like that you know no
normal person
with a happy loving caring upbringing
would make those decisions you know
who's around her to think that's okay
what were the injuries i suffered third
degree burns to
both of my hands my face the top of my
head i always wear a wig now
and my arm i think they all the doctors
at the time thought i would die
you know thinking of thinking back our
babies have third degree burns
over their face which is a big portion
of a baby it's not you know it doesn't
look good so the doctors just made me
comfortable gave me a little painkillers
but ultimately left me to it but when i
didn't die
and i kept chugging on they decided to
get to work and start doing a lot of the
skin grafts that you know when you've
got burns and necessary you have a lot
of infection so they got in quick and
did a lot of operations
i had well over you know four dozen
different
types of operations a lot of them to
save my life
and a lot of them to try make me look as
normal as possible if you can call it
that
i was lucky i survived with a lot of
love and care from the nurses
so when you were in hospital did you
have anyone there to care for you after
that apart from
the medical professionals when i was put
into
hospital it was made quite clear that i
would be taken away from the family
and so i didn't have anyone i was uh
you'd call a child of the state
you know i didn't have parents or a
guardian so i was
yeah as a child of a state of the state
for a long time
when were you adopted so i was fostered
when i was
around six months old and i was lucky
enough to be
adopted by the same family when i was
six years old
so i'm very lucky i always i think
that's sort of that you know i felt like
i won the lottery really i was saved
from the fire and i was
adopted with the same family i was very
lucky
about your birth father they were always
really honest
my mum went with honesty which i think
is the best way age-appropriate honesty
they didn't jump straight in with what
your mom did it sleep with one eye but
imagine
like did you ever feel different as a
child
i did feel different my first
play school i think it was or junior
school i should know this i'm a mum what
sort of first school thing you go to
anyway whatever
um i went there and i
uh i obviously upset one of the girls
there one of the other kids
and her mum asked my the teachers if i
could
be removed because i was upsetting her
child
my face she didn't like it i was scaring
her
even now though even then i was like i
had the
sort of the foresight to know that's
incredibly inappropriate to say that
ever out loud um i was very lucky though
my teachers obviously said no you know
if you don't like it you can remove your
own child this girl's staying so i was
really like i had these people in my
corner
but it was more the fact that people
thought it was okay to say these things
and do these things
it wasn't until i got a bit older that i
felt like my difference was uh something
that was annoying and
you know something that upset me if you
like because i could get over how i
looked
you know you know pretty ugly beautiful
whatever
it doesn't really matter how you look in
that respect i don't think you know
nothing's going to really stop you from
having a good life but what does make an
impact is how people react to you if i
went into a coffee shop
the the waitress awaits wouldn't ask me
what i wanted they would say whoever i
was with
what does she want does she want sugar
coffee
is oh i didn't exist so i didn't have a
mind or i couldn't speak for myself
and that can get kind of tacks in you
know i felt like
i was constantly having to make people
feel comfortable i was constantly having
to wait for people to catch up
i think it's the roadblocks that keep
happening you want to have like a smooth
day
but my day get when i was younger
certainly would always get stopped
because people would want to
pull me in to have a conversation and
sometimes it's nice
but sometimes it would be um
do you know that there's plastic
surgeons that can help you with
your face i'm like oh no [ __ ] has i've
been using paper mache and glasses all
my life
like but in reality they're being nice
they're trying to say like you know i've
got some information i can help you
um and so the intention is actually fine
and they're not being bad but obviously
for me i'm
i'm just trying to like get to work and
have a normal day and i'm having these
things that you're kind of having to
when did you stop you wanted to look for
answers it was when i sort of was
settled i created a nice little bubble
for myself you know
i was enjoying work had a good
relationship i think i kind of knew kids
were on the horizon
and i think i sort of suddenly felt that
need to sort of
understand my past and i wanted to
figure things out because i thought you
know what if i don't do it now i'm
probably not going to do it
i thought it was now or never if i don't
find it out now i'm probably never going
to
find out
can you talk us through what you find
out i went to the fibregate archives
and got hold of my file and i found
out that my mum's husband's mum
was there on the day of the fire the
names were very similar and
she saved me in the fire she also
suffered injuries
and so my mum wasn't actually there at
all i found out
um i had family
alive and i got to meet some of them i
found out
what happened on the day of the fire
that it was
dubious but it was more an accident
than uh an intentional
murder i guess god i've never said that
word um
yeah it was emotional i say this i know
i'm saying this and it probably sounds
like i should be really happy and
smiling but it wasn't like
you know a lovely end
it was still a sad story and there's a
lot of victims around
the story you know it sort of hurt a lot
of people
so it wasn't a happy ending i
i didn't expect happy ending but it
wasn't a happy ending that you'd think
but it was just
i got information and it was nice to
know that my mum didn't
try and hurt me on purpose
do you know what the worst thing is i
can take pain to myself
i'll have it any day of the week but i
can't take it
like i'm a mum now and i just think
sorry
you know if my child went through life
thinking i did that to them and i didn't
it just felt really bad i felt bad so
you know why did i um
why didn't i try
no i knew she died when i was seven
and i found that out that she died and
she had a really hard life like
she had a really hard life she died in a
terrible accident herself
um but yeah i just
why didn't i try imagine like i'm a mum
now and i know what it's like
and for me to think you know i didn't
hate her
for sure i mean i didn't even feel like
i ever had to forgive her anything you
know i just thought she had a tough
life but i just thought that
to figure you know to find out what
actually happened earlier and
you know just i know it doesn't matter
it's not as if it
you know maybe affected her but
it just makes you feel guilty you know
like to think that of someone
it's a horrible thing it's a horrible
thing you know why didn't i question it
your your birth mother was here now yes
what would you like to say
all i can hear in the back of my mind is
i would say i'm sorry
for
not giving her a chance and not
trying to understand her side of the
story more
be strange to put her face to the story
for me i think that would
really cement it all i was finding out
that information changed
in some ways
i think it's hard not to change you
you're going to take
the stories people are going to tell you
you know the adults around you are going
to say one thing you're going to believe
it
you know you meet people and it's quite
nice to judge them so
you can make yourself feel very
comfortable and you can put people in a
box and then you can kind of categorize
everything
and feel very safe but in reality you
don't know really everyone you don't
know the story
it's years down the line that you kind
of really understand someone
and that's why it's really necessary to
be kind and give people a chance
you know and forgive people over and
over again
i was i was sat in my in my parents
living room and it was like
i don't know midnight one o'clock in the
morning i actually flicked the website
back on and in the first half an hour of
the website being live we sold
30 thousand pound in product so to go
from three hundred quid a day to thirty
thousand pound in half an hour
um everything could sold out it was um
it was
absolutely mind-blowing